where do you think it's all headed
do you ever think about where
tried to visualize the entirety of The
evolutionary system and see if there's
an arrow to it and a destination to it
so the best way to understand the future
is to look at the past if you look at
the trajectory then you can kind of
learn something about the direction
which we're heading and if you look at
the trajectory of life on Earth it's
really about information processing so
the the concept of the senses evolving
one after the other you know being like
bacteria are able to do chemotaxes
basically means moving towards a
chemical gradient and that's the first
thing that you need to sort of hunt down
food the next step after that is being
able to actually perceive light
so all life on this planet and all life
that we know about evolved on this
rotating Rock every 24 hours you get
sunlight and dark sunlight and dark and
light is a source of energy light is
also information about where is up light
is all kinds of you know things so you
can you can basically now start
perceiving light
and then perceiving shapes Beyond just
the sort of single photoreceptor you can
now have complex eyes or multiple eyes
and then start perceiving motion or
perceiving Direction perceiving shapes
and then you start building
infrastructure on the cognitive
apparatus to start processing this
information and making sense of the
environment building more complex models
of the environment so if you look at
that trajectory of evolution what we're
experiencing now and humans are
basically according to this sort of
information theoretic view of evolution
humans are basically the next natural
step and it's perhaps no surprise that
we became the dominant species of the
planet because yes there's so many
dimensions in which some animals are way
better than we are but at least on the
cognitive Dimension we're just simply
unsurpassed on this planet and and
perhaps the universe but the the concept
that if you now trace this forward
we talked a little bit about
evolvability and how things get better
at evolving one possibility is that the
next layer of evolution
builds the next layer of evolution and
what we're looking at now with humans in
AI is that having mastered this
information capability that humans have
from this quote-unquote old Hardware
this basically you know biological
evolved system that kind of you know
somehow in the environment of Africa and
then in subsequent environments are sort
of dispersing through the globe was
evolutionarily advantageous
that has now created
technology which now has a capability of
solving many of these cognitive tasks it
doesn't have all the baggage of the
previous revolutionary layers but maybe
the next round of evolution on Earth is
self-replicating AI where we're actually
using our current smarts to build better
programming languages and the
programming languages to build you know
chat GPT and that to then build the next
layer of software that will then sort of
help AI speed up and it's lovely that
we're coexisting with this AI that sort
of the creators of this next layer of
evolution in this next stage are still
around to help guide it and hopefully
will be for the rest of Eternity as
partners but it's also nice to think
about it as just simply the next stage
of evolution where you've kind of
extracted away the biological needs like
if you look at animals most of them
spend 80 of their waking hours hunting
for food or building shelter humans
maybe one percent of that time and then
the rest is left to creative Endeavors
an AI doesn't have to worry about
shelter Etc so basically it's all living
in the cognitive space so in a way it
might just be a very natural sort of
next step to think about Evolution and
that's that's on the on the sort of
purely cognitive side if you're now
think about humans themselves
the ability to understand and comprehend
our own genome again the ultimate layer
of introspection
gives us now the ability to even mess
with his Hardware not just augment our
capabilities through interacting and
collaborating with AI but also perhaps
understand the neural Pathways that are
necessary for
you know
empathetic thinking for for justice for
this and this and that and sort of help
augment human capabilities through you
know neuronal interventions through
chemical interventions through
electrical interventions to basically
help steer the human you know bag of
Hardware that we kind of evolved with
into greater capabilities
and then ultimately by understanding not
just the wiring of neurons and the
functioning of neurons but even the
genetic code we could even at one point
in the future start thinking about well
can we get rid of psychiatric disease
can we get rid of neurodegeneration can
we get rid of dementia and start perhaps
even augmenting human capabilities not
just
getting rid of disease
can we Tinker with the genome with the
hardware
or getting closer to the hardware
without having to deeply understand the
baggage
in the way we've disposed of the baggage
in our software systems with AI
to some degree not fully but to some
degree can we do the same with the
genome or is the genome deeply
integrated into this bag I wouldn't want
to get rid of the baggage the baggage
which makes this awesome so the fact
that I'm sometimes angry and sometimes
hungry and sometimes angry
is perhaps contributing to my creativity
I don't want to be dispassionate I don't
want to be another like you know robot I
you know I want to get in trouble and I
want to sort of say the wrong thing and
I want to sort of you know make an
awkward comment and sort of push myself
into
you know reactions and responses and
things that
can get just people thinking differently
and
I I think our society is moving towards
a humorless uh space where everybody's
so afraid to say the wrong thing that
people kind of start quitting on mass
and start like not liking their jobs and
stuff like that maybe we should be uh
kind of embracing that human aspect a
little bit more in all of that baggage
aspect and uh not necessarily thinking
about replacing it on the contrary like
embracing it in sort of this coexistence
of the cognitive and the emotional hard
words so embracing and celebrating the
diversity
that Springs from the baggage versus
uh kind of uh pushing towards and
empowering this kind of pull towards
Conformity yeah and in fact with the
Advent of AI I would say and these
seemingly extremely intelligent systems
that sort of conform can perform tasks
that we thought of as extremely
intelligent at the blink of an eye
this might democratize
intellectual Pursuits instead of just
simply wanting the same type of brains
that you know carry out
specific ways of thinking we can like
instead of just always only wanting say
the mathematically extraordinary to go
to the same universities what you could
see simply say is like who needs that
anymore you know we now have ai maybe
what we should really be thinking about
is the diversity and the power that
comes with the diversity where AI can do
the math and then we should be getting a
bunch of humans that sort of think
extremely differently from each other
and maybe that's the true cradle of
innovation
but
AI can also these large language models
can also be with just a few prompts
essentially fine-tuned to be diverse
from the center
so the prompts can really take you away
into unique territory you can ask the
model to act
in a certain way and it will start to
act in that way is that possible that uh
the language models could also have some
of the magical diversity that makes us
so damn interesting so I would say
humans are the same way so basically
when you when you sort of prompt humans
to basically you know you know give an
environment to act a particular way
they change their own behaviors and um
you know the old saying is show me your
friends and I'll tell you who you are
more like show me your friends and I'll
tell you who you'll become so it's not
necessarily that you choose friends that
are like you but I mean that's the first
step but then the second step is that
you know the kind of behaviors that you
find normal in your circles are the
behaviors that you'll start espousing
and that type of meta Evolution where
every action we take not only shapes our
current action and the result of this
action but it also shapes our future
actions by shaping the environment in
which those future actions will be taken
every time you you carry out a
particular Behavior it's not just a
consequence for today but it's also a
consequence for tomorrow because you're
reinforcing that neural pathway so in a
way self-discipline is a self-fulfilling
prophecy
and by
behaving the way that you want to behave
and choosing people that are like you
and sort of exhibiting those behaviors
that are
sort of desirable
you end up creating that that
environment as well so it is a kind of
life itself is a kind of prompting
mechanism super complex the friends you
choose the environments you choose the
way you modify the environment that you
choose yes but that seems like that
process is much less efficient than a
large language model you can literally
get a large language model through a
couple of prompts to be
a mix of Shakespeare and David Bowie
right you can very aggressively change
in a way that's stable and convincing
you really transform
through a couple of prompts the behavior
of the model
into something very different from the
original so well before
Chachi PT yeah I would tell my students
just ask you know what would manoli say
right now and you you guys all have a
pretty good emulator of me right now yes
and uh I don't know if you know the
programming Paradigm of the rubber
duckling where you basically explain to
the rubber duckling that's just sitting
there exactly what you did with your
code and why you have a bug and just
like the act of explaining you'll kind
of figure it out yes I woke up one
morning from a dream where I was giving
a lecture in this Amphitheater and one
of my friends was basically giving me
some deep evolutionary Insight on how
cancer genomes and cancer cells evolve
and I woke up with a very elaborate
discussion that I was giving and a very
elaborate set of insights that he had
that I was projecting onto my friend in
my sleep and obviously this was my dream
so my own neurons were capable of doing
that but they only did that Under The
Prompt of you are now piyush Gupta
you are a professor in cancer genomics
you're an expert in that field what do
you say so I feel that we all have that
inside us that we have that capability
of basically saying I don't know what
the right thing is but let me ask my
virtual legs what would you do and
virtual X would say be kind I'm like oh
yes
or something like that and even though I
myself might not be able to do it
unprompted
and uh the my favorite prompt is think
step by step and I'm like you know this
also works on my 10 year old
when he tries to solve a math equation
all in one step I know exactly what
mistake you'll make but if I prompt it
with oh please think step by step then
you sort of gets in a mindset and I
think it's also part of the way that
Chachi PT was actually trained this
whole sort of human in the loop
reinforcement learning
has probably reinforced these types of
behaviors whereby having this feedback
loop you kind of aligned AI better to
the prompting opportunities by humans
yeah prompting human like reasoning
steps the step-by-step kind of thinking
yeah but it does seem to be I suppose it
just puts a mirror to our own
capabilities and so we can be truly
impressed by our own cognitive
capabilities because the variety of what
you can try because we don't usually
have this kind of
we can't play with our own mind
rigorously
through python code right yeah so this
allows us to really play with
um all all of human wisdom and knowledge
or at least knowledge at our fingertips
and then mess with that little mind that
can think and speak in all kinds of ways
what's unique is that as I mentioned
earlier every one of us was trained by
different subset of human culture
and jtbt was trained on all of it yeah
and the difference there is that it
probably has the ability to emulate
almost any every one of us yeah the fact
that you can figure out where that is in
cognitive behavioral space just by a few
prompts it's pretty impressive but the
fact that that exists somewhere is you
know absolutely beautiful and
the fact that it's encoded in an
orthogonal way from the knowledge I
think is also beautiful the fact that
somehow through these extreme
overparameterization of AI models it was
able to somehow figure out that context
knowledge and form are separable and
that you can sort of describe scientific
knowledge in a haiku in the form of I
don't know Shakespeare or something that
tells you something about the um the
decoupling and the decouplerability of
these types of aspects of human psyche
and that's part of the science of this
whole thing so these large language
models are you know days old
in terms of this kind of leap that
they've taken and it'll be interesting
to do this kind of analysis on them of
contact of the separation of context
form and knowledge where exactly does
that happen yeah there's already sort of
initial investigations but it's very
hard to figure out where is there a
particular uh parameter set of
parameters that are responsible for a
particular piece of knowledge or a
particular context or a particular style
speaking so with convolutional neural
networks interpretability had many good
advances because we can kind of
understand them there's a structure to
them there's a locality to them and we
can kind of understand the different
layers have different sort of ranges
that they're looking at so we can look
at activation features and basically see
where you know where does that
correspond to
with large language models
it's perhaps a little more complicated
but I think it's still achievable in the
sense that we could kind of ask well
what kind of prompts does this generate
if I sort of drop out this part of the
network then what happens and sort of
start getting at a language to even
describe these types of aspects of human
be behavioral psychology if you wish
from the spoken part in the language
part and the advantage of that is that
it might actually teach us something
about humans as well like you you know
we might not have words to describe
these types of aspects right now but
when somebody speaks some particular way
it might remind us of a friend that we
know from here there there and if we had
better language for describing that
these Concepts might become more
apparent in our own human psyche and
then we might be able to encode them
better in machines themselves I mean
both probably you and I
would have certain interests with the
base model would open Echo is the base
model which is before the the alignment
of the
reinforcement learning with human
feedback and and before the
AI safety based kind of censorship of
the model
it would be fascinating to explore to
investigate the ways that the model can
generate hate speech
the kind of hate that humans are capable
of it would be fascinating or the kind
of uh of course like uh sexual language
or the kind of romantic language or the
all kinds of ideologies can I get it to
be a communist can I get it to be a
fascist can I get it to be a capitalist
can I get it to be all these kinds of
things and see which parts get activated
or not because it would be fascinating
to sort of explore at the individual
mind level and at a societal level where
do these ideas
um take hold what is the fundamental
core of those ideas maybe the communism
fascism capitalism democracy are all
actually connected by the fact that the
human heart the human mind is drawn to
ideology
to it's a centralizing idea and maybe we
need a neural network to remind us of
that I like the concept that the human
mind is somehow tied to ideology and I
think that goes back to the the
profitability of jgbt the fact that you
can kind of say well think in this
particular way now and the fact that
humans have infected words for
encapsulating these types of behaviors
and it's hard to know how much of that
is innate and how much of that was like
passed on from language to language
but basically if you look at the
evolution of language you can kind of
see how young are these words in the
history of language Evolution that
describe these types of behaviors like
you know kindness and anger and jealousy
Etc if these words are very similar from
language to language it might suggest
that they're very ancient if they're
very different it might suggest that
this concept may have emerged
independently in each different language
and so and so forth so
looking at the phylogeny the history The
evolutionary traces of language at the
same time as people moving around that
we can now Trace thanks to genetics
is a fascinating way of understanding
the human psyche and also understanding
sort of how these types of behaviors
emerge and to go back to your idea about
sort of exploring the system unfiltered
I mean in a ways as a psychiatric
hospitals are full of those be full of
those people so basically people whose
mind is uncontrollable yes who have kind
of gone adrift in specific locations of
their psyche and I I do find this
fascinating basically
you know watching movies that are trying
to capture the essence of troubled minds
I think is teaching us so much about our
everyday selves because many of us are
able to sort of control our minds and
are able to have somehow somehow hide
these emotions and
but every time I see somebody who's
troubled I I see versions of myself
maybe not as extreme but I can sort of
empathize with these behaviors and
you know I see bipolar I see
schizophrenia I see depression I see
autism I see so many different aspects
that we kind of have names for and
crystallize in specific individuals
and I think all of us have that all of
us have sort of just this
multi-dimensional brain and genetic
variations that push us in these
directions environmental exposures and
traumas that push us in these directions
environmental behaviors that are
reinforced by the kind of friends that
we chose or friends that we were stuck
with because of the environments that we
grew up in so in a way a lot of these
types of
behaviors
are within the Vector span of every
human it's just that the magnitude of
those vectors is generally smaller for
most people
because they haven't inherited that
particular set of genetic variants or
because they haven't been exposed to
those environments basically or
something about the mechanism of
reinforcement learning with human
feedback didn't quite work for them so
it's fascinating to think about that's
what we do we have this capacity to have
all these
psychiatric or behaviors associated with
psychiatric disorders but we through the
alignment process as we go through their
parents we kind of we know to suppress
them yeah we know the kind of control
every human that grows up in this in
this world spends several decades being
shaped into place yeah and without that
you know maybe we would have the
unfiltered chatgpt4 laughs